[Musique]
pas de doute c'est vraiment du mal on le
reconnaît bon à sa forme
c'est vrai de pavés mais surtout à son
odeur cette odeur véhémente comme disait
curnonsky le prince des gastronomes qui
aimait beaucoup d'ailleurs le mariage
le maroilles pardon puisqu'il avait
baptisé le roi des fromages obligé de
lui qu'il avait cette saveur tonitruante
qui résonnait comme le son du saxophone
dans la symphonie des fromages belle
formule mais il semble d'ailleurs que le
maroilles incline au lyrisme puisque
j'ai découvert aussi un poème d'un
prêtre local qui disait de lui il est
doux il est tendre il vous suit dans
l'appartement
il lui manque la parole brésil a le
sentiment et oui alors bon il ya
beaucoup d'autres fromages normes
vous avez un bel échantillon là devant
moi tout ça c'est fabriqué dans le nord
il ya le vieux lille
on appelle aussi le puant est bon et
vous devinez pourquoi qui est encore un
peu plus violent chanson another que le
maroilles il ya la boulette d'avesnes au
goût très très puissant
elle aussi le fromage du mont-des-cats
qui fabriqué par les moines les moines
trappistes du mont-des-cats vous avez le
verbal au site avec elie par des
religieuses et religieux de l'abbaye
d'orval
il ya le couac est ce qui a encore il ya
la tome de cambrai il ya le à la
mimolette des flandres on appelle aussi
le violent qui est un fromage qui
vieillit très longtemps et qui a
beaucoup de saveur et que je vous
recommande par exemple pour déguster un
vin il met en valeur tous les vins avec
lequel on le déguste mais enfin de tous
ces pros maj le plus connu et le plus
ancien il n'y a pas de doute c'est le
maroilles il a plus de mille ans et
qu'il aurait été inventée dit-on par les
moines de l'abbaye de maroilles au 10ème
siècle
d'ailleurs le village de maroilles a
récemment par récemment en 1966 a fêté
son millénaire et lui à élever un
monument c'est d'ailleurs le seul
monument au monde à la gloire d'un
fromage on ne fabrique plus
malheureusement aujourd'hui le maroilles
à maroilles même mais il ya encore sur
place à un affineur
le chômage est affiné dans les caves de
l'ancienne abbaye et l'affinage dans le
maroilles c'est très important
bon au départ il faut s'aider de vaches
bien sûr qu'ils aient cru produit dans
la région
mais le fromage ne prend toute sa saveur
cette saveur très particulière que au
cours de la finale qui dure quatre mois
[Musique]
le maroilles est un fromage à croûte
lavée donc c'est pour ceux ci que nous
l'avons une fois par semaine sur toutes
ses faces alors ça lui chante en
commençant toujours par le le plus
affinées jusqu'à au moins deux fines et
aura tenté le serment ce qui t'as un
dirigent de la couleur du maroilles dans
le temps on faisait cela avec de la
bière mais la bière n'est plus collecté
dans le temps donc maintenant nous le
faisons je de l'eau ils disent elles de
maroilles qui faisait les délices
paraît-il du roi louis xiv qui se
faisait livrer à la cour de versailles
eh bien on peut le déguster sur place à
maroilles dans une grande salle qui
était autrefois le réfectoire des moines
et on peut aussi y manger la flamiche au
maroilles qui est la grande spécialité
de l'avesnois et l'avesnois le pays du
maroilles croyez moi c'est une très
jolie région qui vaut le déplacement
mais le maroilles et bien vous pouvez le
faire aussi chez vous et nos familles
perron bien sûr est là pour vous dire
comment faire cette la miche omar alors
moi je sais déjà amené le maroilles
bonjour piro bonjour pierre pasqua vous
serrez la main parce que quand ça va ça
va bien bon pyros et voyons vous le
présente plus c'est un restaurateur
lillois le bistrot de pirou aujourd'hui
on a une nouvelle cuisine s'il vous
plaît bureau alors là j'étais gâté
on est bien on met la place selon moi je
peux bouger avec ma corpulence tout va
bien alors oui vous avez bien bichonner
ses biens voilà bon mais on est là pour
parler pour faire cette émission
maroilles islamique en fait bon c'est
quoi alors une famille chez unsa alors
on peut faire voyez là c'est ce que je
suis en panne sèche en train de red bull
pour gagner un peu de temps parce qu'on
on va pas trop traîner quand même donc
c'est une tarte qu'on peut faire à base
de pâte foncez pas de briser ou alors
carrément une pâte feuilletée
aujourd'hui c'est a pas de vérité qu'on
offre alors ici on a mis on appris du
feuilletage mais surtout pouvait prendre
de la pâte a foncé ou de la pâte brisée
et c'est comme vous voulez mais là le
feuilletage va très bien et puis disons
que c'est la même c'est la même pâte
qu'on met toujours au bistrot de pierrot
qui est une classique mais souvent vite
retire on fait des petites on fait des
petites tours pierre et ici on va donc
une grande tourtier bon voilà alors ça
va les bee gees feuilletée j'ai quand
même c'est un petit peu plus léger
voulez vous la faites surtout pas la
faire trop fine juste ce qu'il faut à
laquelle passe bien alors qu'on fait pas
de manière
voyez le va tout seul voilà voilà
mesdames et j'ai de la chance ça
correspond à la fin on essaie de vous le
montrer vraiment il n'y a pas de trucage
ça paraît incroyable et oui c'est
vraiment comme ça et je crois que c'est
ce qui ce qu'on aime bien de vous
montrer alors regardez ce que vous devez
surtout fait c'est le bien s'arranger
pour pas qu'elle soit versée pour pas
revu la crème passe à travers
voilà alors le fer sommairement pas
s'amuser à trop fignoler faut montrer
que ces faits maison voilà ça c'est fait
un petit coup de rouleau
ah oui pour découper la pâte
voilà la pâte et découper
voilà
en pointe petit crochet dans ma nouvelle
cuisine vous piquer un peu la patte pour
pas qu'elle gonfle de trop alors piqué
c'est ce que j'explique souvent c'est
pas trop et il faut pas faire trop non
plus de la percée faut juste piquer un
peu pour pas qu'elle gonfle alors là on
va vous expliquer vraiment la recette du
maroilles vraiment c'est la recette
classique équipe a très bien fait et
vous l'avez senti comme dans l'avesnois
aussi comme dans l'avesnois et vous la
mettez à poser un quart d'heure vingt
minutes cinq dix minutes ça va aussi bon
ici on va nous donner un peu plus vite
mais vous la mettez au frigo frais ou
dans la cave un quart d'heure vingt
minutes a reposé je suis la poste dans
mon frigo ya du monde voilà voilà
et pendant ce temps là alors pendant ce
temps là je vais donc battre mais eux
épluchez montbard où elle peut tout
d'abord on va d'abord être touché le
maroilles alors pour une flamiche de
comme la oumma finnois flamiche de huit
heures soit à peu près 50 g de 50 à 60 g
de maroilles pas personne donc on va
éplucher le my way l'agro maroilles 1
700 grammes alors là honnêtement je
trouve quand même en maître du maroilles
parce qu'il ya des gens enfin surtout
des restaurateurs donc j'ai dû attendre
idiote mais pour ça quand même bien vous
demain voilà alors voulu l'éplucher mais
grossièrement s'il reste un peu de cool
c'est pas grave il faut la croûte parce
qu'en puisant s'il voulait donc ya pas
de problème si vaste un peu trop ses
passages à la croûte non c'est pas ça
qui donne un peu non on ne peut pas tout
mettre la route non plus parce que si
vous voulez c'est un peu trop fort alors
voyez je les fais chier grossièrement
j'avais le plus gros de la croûte
voilà alors là on va se baser à peu près
on va en penser à une grande tourtière
vous allez voir il faut bien admettre
dans le fond surtout surtout chez la
ménagère
on ne regarde quand même pas un morceau
de maroilles il faut que ce soit quand
même bien le goût de maroilles donc là
il va être prêts sous les après un coupé
en lamelles don pour mettre là je vais
donc préparé mon appareil alors là c'est
vraiment tout ça c'est une recette
vraiment qu'il va bien pour les dames où
les messieurs je leur dis parce que soit
naïf pour la cuisine on va donc casser
les oeufs
je prends mes oeufs dans mon frigo
ça se mange acer en entrée si on entrait
mais on peut très bien les prendre
on peut très bien le prendre le soir le
soir c'est ce qui fait que c'est ce
qu'on fait dans les plantes on peut très
bien les prendre le soir avec une salade
salir les gens il faut une famille s'il
faut une salade ou pas peu de jambon cru
et le soir on mange une flamiche avec la
salade des gens m'ont plus sympas du
dimanche soir qui va très très bien
alors une famille c'est évidemment tous
très chaud très chaud mais l'idéal c'est
quand même de la cuire et de la faire au
dernier moment c'est vraiment délicieux
voilà tellement de tort au total or pour
une flamiche comme la deux de huit
personnes
je vais mettre ça que cela on peut aller
de 5 à 6 lors vent médecin qu'on va
montrer qu'on fait des économies de
temps en temps voilà 5 5 cuillères de
crème fraîche ça va tout seul c'est la
bonne crème
c'est comme pour le garde-fou c'est un
peu c'est un peu toujours ce mélange de
crème et duff qui est là vous mettez du
poids bien plus vrai et on va pas mettre
de sel parce qu le maroilles et à
s'installer
si on met du sel à chaque fois on a le
tour là les gens vous disent que c'est
trop salée et donc c'est quand même un
petit problème alors on va prendre de la
muscade
il est à la tête quand même de mettre
des noiséens mieux dès que la musique a
pulvérisé alors vous mêmes danois à
l'orgue et de la muscade
alors ça dépend des goûts bon il faut
qu'on le sent que vous la muscade ne
faut pas trop non plus ipod juste ce
qu'il faut voilà un peu de muscade
voilà et on va et emballante mélange
toujours pareil alors là la nouveauté
par rapport disant la terre taïba c'est
là que vous allez mourir je vais mettre
un petit peu de dire bravo aux dents qui
va remplacer le lait alors on est un
petit peu de bière brune
si vous voulez pour redonner le goût de
la bière qui s'évaporait à la famille
donc on est un petit peu bien bruno
magnier c'est ce qu'on fait là voilà
c'est l'appareil à la tarte à la
rhubarbe
alors je vais rechercher ma patte voyez
là il ya à peu près 5 6 minutes je vais
repasser matin mais normalement si vous
voulez c'est un quart d'heure vingt
minutes c'est l'idéal
comme ça ne bougera pas bon là il faut
faire vite quand même voilà alors je je
recoupe foncièrement toujours grossier
sony fallait bien en petites lamelles
mais voyez pas trop fine juste ce qu'il
faut quand fondent ensemble bien goût de
maroilles voyez alors là et vous la
poser à plat dans votre tour vous voyez
avait tout bien recouvertes recouverte
de mon bar one way en est bien parti
donc d'accord on ne vient pas de
problème c'est bien copieux alors c'est
un mal au dos et servat mais à peu près
500 il n'a pas pesé il n'y a pas de jeu
point une petite louche et je vais
mettre mon appareil au dessus alors
voyez c'est vraiment pas sorcier et ça
prend vraiment pas beaucoup de temps là
nous allons la mettre dans le tour
la famille si on peut dire elle est
prête alors la température du four ont
normalement 2 200 degrés à 220° 200° c
bien de 120 degrés pendant 25 minutes à
peu près dans la fosse aux impasses que
je l'affronterai jouer rail est allumée
donc tout le show face de 120° voilà et
je le pose dans mon four à 200° balles
cinq minutes à 220 degrés ça va tout
seul
voilà donc les gens s'y sent pas de
pandas bon et bien on a été patient 1 40
minutes
bayer maintenant elle est un fait quatre
ans qu'elle va être très très belle
regardez pierre voyage fait dégonflées
être très très bien qu'on fait alors ce
qu'il faut surtout c'est pas la dépasser
200 degrés 220° si mal wagon si elle va
monter trop fort oui car si elle est
belle
regardez olalalala alors je crois enfin
c'est vraiment là la vraie solution marc
gallet si elle est mal gardé comme un
lego ça va être brûlant là normalement
il faut me fait attendre cinq six
minutes lors on la sort du fou avant
d'aller couper évidemment à la base des
ailes basses dégonfler un petit peu
voyez c'est normal ça sent plus du tout
le lot de tout à l'heure s'est atténuée
par la compare les yeux c'est vraiment
délicieux un petit peu quand même
alors goûtez moi ça
dai
[Musique]